Every one of these dudes bumping the Kendrick Lamar song,
I wanna hear them loud as fuck when they see a woman struggling
or they see a single mother that, like,
need something.
Or every single one of those motherfuckers
better be caught up on their child support and, like,
fully up in their child's lives.
how the fuck can you listen to one of those Kendrick Lamar songs
and then talk shit on your baby mama?
Or talk shit on a single mother?
Or talk shit or fucking.
Do you know what I'm saying?
You better not be.
They not like us.
They not like us,
but you just fucking like them.
You better watch your fucking step
if you're bumping that motherfucking song
for fucking real.